going into Avengers endgame fans were
prepared for everything the surviving
squad pulling off an epic mission fallen
heroes getting adjusted and returning to
the world of the living
Thanos tasting is just desserts and much
more they were also bracing themselves
for the possibility that some who were
spared in that OSes universe decimating
snap and Avengers infinity war was sadly
not make it to the end this time around
if you haven't figured it out by now
there are major Avengers and game
spoilers in coming still here that's
continued endgame featured a fewer
deaths than anyone had anticipated of
the deaths in the movie one was heroic
and heart-wrenching another wasn't so
much a passing away as it was a passing
on and one was completely unexpected
it's that last one that we need to talk
about it's time to address what happened
to Black Widow in Avengers endgame in
the first act of the film Black Widow
serves as a strong leader who keeps her
surviving Avengers in contact with one
another five years after the decimation
she organizes meetings at Avengers HQ
checking in with the other heroes around
the galaxy to receive status updates on
how the earth and other worlds are
faring Black Widow also makes her
personal mission to track down her
fellow original Avenger Clint Barton who
abandoned his Hawkeye identity and
assumed his ruthless Ronan persona after
the snap took his wife and children all
this felt like endgame was showing
viewers of Black Widow could rise to the
occasion to marshal the Avengers and
company after they complete that time
heist if one or all of her teammates bit
the dust the Black Widow could step up
to continue leading the Avengers she has
the skill and the personality and she's
been acting as a de facto supervisor of
the team for five whole years
Vasil things pan out Black Widow never
gets the chance to continue leading the
way she doesn't even get to finish the
hero's mission to travel back to the
present day because Black Widow is the
first hero to die in Avengers endgame
her death comes when she and Hawkeye
head back a few years into the past and
touched down on for Mia their ammo
planet where the soul stone is located
as everyone knows in order to acquire
the soul stone one must make an equal
exchange
soul for a soul that is tossed his
adoptive daughter Gomorrah off the clip
on Bonilla to cool the soul stone his
own and Black Widow and Hawkeye must do
something similar in endgame and see the
her or him they can't both surviving at
the soul stone black widow makes the
bold decision to sacrifice herself and
allow hawkeye to retrieve the soul stone
help the Avengers bring the dust hip
back to life and reunite with his family
and we know she dies the film shows
Black Widow laying motionless on the
ground blood pooling around her head
longtime MCU fans are understandably
pretty upset and confused about a well
the movie made it seem like this little
Chan's black widow can be revived this
isn't actually the end for the hero in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Marvel
Studios is working on a black widow solo
movie directed by Australian filmmaker
Kate Shortland and is likely aiming to
release it in theaters sometime in the
next few years
details about the film's plot are sparse
right now but it's reportedly planned to
be a prequel set just after 2010's Iron
Man 2 and before the events of 2012's
Avengers meanwhile other reports claim
that Black Widow partially takes place
in the time when the Tashia served as an
agent for the Soviet Union's KGB
organization and then skips ahead to 15
years after the fall of the KGB in the
1980s Marvel has yet to confirm any
story specifics though a prequel slash
origin story set up sounds pretty
plausible that would allow for an easy
explanation as to why Black Widow was
back on the big screen the studio could
also use the same digital d aging
technology it did with samuel l.jackson
for his role as Nick Fury in Captain
Marvel which is set in 1995 to make
Johansson look younger for a black widow
origin story meanwhile the Avengers
endgame isn't the true end of phase 3 of
the MCU there's still time for the
franchise to hint at what's next for
Black Widow she has connections to
shield and to Nick Fury having joined
the team after working for the KGB and
we know Fiore and agent Maria Hill will
appear in the real face recloser
spider-man far from home it's possible
the upcoming film could we even mentions
of black widows past or feature a
post-credits scene set a few decades in
the past that teases the black widows
solo movie after all a black widow is a
kind of spider then again maybe not
it's all a mystery for now but
should find comfort and knowing that
they haven't seen the last of Black
Widow even after her devastating death
in endgame check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite Marvel movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]